speaking of games
video games got to ask you about those
okay you mentioned diablo maybe you're a
fan of diablo yeah yeah
yeah all right he's great he likes
skyrim skyrim was great too
like the elder scrolls i actually bought
the game that the elder scrolls was
based on do you know that
so uh way back in the day the elder
scrolls series was inspired by a game
called legends of valor
that i played when i was a little kid
and it doesn't actually have an ending
they ran out of money before they
finished it so they just kind of like
put this little
thing on and said okay but you never
finish it so i actually bought all the
intellectual properties you know the
case all that i didn't know there was a
connection between legends of valencia
yeah
yeah i forget the name the guy was it
todd something uh
at bethesda he uh he wasn't he played it
he was inspired by it and then he
created arena right after
uh playing it that was such a good game
arena daggerfall
yeah yeah yeah da i had a copy of
daggerfall when i was a kid but it had a
bug in so when you left the dungeon it
would crash
and this was before like you can get an
easy patch for it so i never actually
played daggerfall i
entered in through morrowind yeah
no the daggerfall was the the
fascinating thing we're just jumping all
over but we'll return to legends of alex
i won't ask you about that but
daggerfall was fascinating because i
think
of all the other skull games it was like
the largest
because it was uh like randomly
generated right it would like randomly
generate the worlds the the dungeons and
so on which is fascinating to think
about like how big can you make the
world
uh both in actuality and feel
like it's incredible to have a video
game that i don't know how many video
games do this
well where the feeling is you can be
lost here forever
you can you can live here because most
video games have like a bottom it feels
like you can run out of stuff
but daggerfall was like i could just
keep doing this right
at least that's what i felt at the time
but yeah why what the heck
legends of valor what's the idea there
well i mean
it's there's really nothing about it
that's super compelling today
i mean there's a nostalgia of youth
that's there but i mean it doesn't even
have a class system a level system
the combat system is terrible there's no
journal the magic system is terrible and
so forth and so i
i just wanted to start somewhere and i
felt like that would be an incredibly
fun
overhaul project i kind of got the idea
from beam dog studios when they did
another one of my favorite games
remember baldar's gate yeah they did
that brother's gate too oh yeah the
enhanced edition was great
they should have never just done thrown
a ball they should have done an actual
proper sequel
and i got down that whole road um but
anyway
uh i got the idea there i said well take
some old piece of ip
and then you can kind of retrofit it and
clean it up and what's nice about
legends of valor is it's like blank
slate you can
do your own elder scrolls you can create
your own class system and level system
and so forth you could write some
beautiful exciting fun
narratives for that and also it gives me
a chance to explore
a lot of things i think should be
dragged into game development like
algorithmically generated music
is one example the problem with sound
games as you mentioned you play
lots and lots of hours but your sound
content is much smaller
so you have tons of repetition in the
soundtrack so what if you could
connect the music to the state of the
game world and
automatically through some process will
generate music and there's actually
people who study this
you know and so that's one dimension the
other thing is you have things like gpt3
and so forth there was a great game uh
event zero uh and it came out like 2016
where you could actually have a dialogue
with an ai
uh and you're like a marooned astronaut
on a space station that's abandoned
and you have to somehow work with this
ai through communicating with it
to convince you to to take you home but
the ai is a bit
duplicitous and i don't want to spoil
the plot of the game because it's such a
cool game but it's actually like a paint
by numbers it's almost like zork
where you you don't have pre-selected
dialogue you actually type in the
terminal
and the ai will reply to you back and
forth and this was 2016 and it's like
things have gotten an order magnitude
better
so the evolution of that tech i think
within the next five years brought into
video games could you give you
incredibly cool dialogue
inside the inside of the game so
algorithmically generated music better
dialogue better gameplay mechanics also
i'd love to explore
alternative physics systems you know
alternative geometries
like you know hyperbolic geometry or
these types of things
and there's actually hyperbolica is a
game that does that wow
and you can do down the euclidean
geometry as well and bring those
elements into a game design
and that's what we'll do is legends of
valor so it'll be kind of like skyrim
but with a lot of really cool new
it's got like uh i saw aerosmith years
ago and he was out there he's like do
you like the old you like new
kind of middle you know so you're
going for the middle yeah
i'm gonna try to do some of the old and
some of the new and you know bring it in
so that'll be a lot of fun
um and what's nice about it is that uh
there's a lot of of new play in the
market because of the microsoft
acquisition of bethesda
they've been losing employees like crazy
and there's a lot of belief that elder
scrolls six will
not live up to expectations because
microsoft will tweet
okay listen to me i will go into i'm i'm
all about love
uh on the internet but i will go hard at
you microsoft if you screw up elder
scrolls
well we might have to do a spiritual
successor right it might have to happen
with legends of valor you never know
but it's a passion project so i have no
time for it at all it's like so low on
my list of things to do so i'll probably
do it in 2022
2023 and we'll build a nice crew and
we'll do it in wyoming
probably in wheatland or some really
small town and we'll import everybody
and then we'll have to build the whole
city up like elin is doing here in texas
it'll it'll be a fun project well i like
programmatically generated music you
mentioned baldur's gate
there's by the way haskell frameworks
for that u-turpy is one for generating
music
yeah for doing it for i wonder how
successful that could be because i i
remember baldur's gay was the first game
where i realized music is so important
to the game
i it was the thing i remembered about
the game it was the reason
that it was the thing i thought about
when i was away from the game
is like that the feeling it created that
music i
i don't even remember the music anymore
but i remember the music
yeah jeremy soul i think was the
composer yeah
it was great and actually getting like
ramen giuotti or bear
to do that it would be so cool
okay this is awesome uh ridiculous
question what's the
maybe let's say top three greatest video
games of all time
uh yeah balder's gate is definitely the
top three arcanum is my favorite game
and arcane was
troika games was just this amazing
studio where
they they took the time to build
probably the
the most compelling game worlds in the
case of arcanum it takes place in look
kind of like a 19th century victorian
england play so steampunk
but then there's also magic inside this
game world and there's this
crazy juxtaposition between magic and
technology and the more technology you
have magic stops working
the more magic you have it disrupts
technology so all the people on the
magic side hate the technology people
and vice versa
and so you're just this character in
this game world and you're just trying
to figure out like where you fit
and uh it has this incredible plot where
you're you're kind of just a stowaway on
a zeppelin that gets shot down
and you get dragged into this conspiracy
and you have to kind of figure out the
conspiracy as you go through the whole
game world and you meet all these
different races like the elves and the
dwarves and so forth
and they've all been impacted by the
proliferation of technology in different
ways like the humans used steam engines
to clear cut all the forest and it
caused a lot of problems
the dwarves leaked that technology to
the humans and so they kind of got
exiled for it
and so forth and you have to decide like
where do you fit all this and you have a
lot of choices as a player you can be on
the magic side the technology side kind
of be
neutral there's like 40 different
endings for the game
it's just incredible this is all like 2
000 and you talk about a procedurally
generated world
you have a quick travel but if you want
you can just walk and the world randomly
generates but it's not like daggerfall
where there's interesting things along
the way
so it was really ahead of its time and
it was kind of the last of a generation
of games
um it was based on the same framework
that interplay used for
fallout the original fallout fallout 2.
so that was really a cool step
how were the graphics they were not as
central oh it's isometric
three uh top down so oh cool yeah kind
of like the fallout look and so
it it doesn't hold up super well today
but
that was never the point it was more of
a story driven game but it was one of
the
very few games where at the very end of
the game you could actually talk the
villain into killing himself instead of
instead of fighting you
if you if you and you had to really work
at it you had to become a master of
persuasion and get your charisma score
maxed out and learn all this stuff along
the way
and you have this philosophical debate
over the nature of life and death with
him that's amazing
yeah and then you're just like by the
way you're wrong and here's why and he's
like oh yeah you got a point i'm just
going to kill myself
and i was like wow this is great
planescape torment is uh the other one i
think is probably the greatest
was it called lanescape yeah it's
another one on the infinity engine which
was what was used for baldur's gate so
it looks like balder's gate
and god that was such an incredibly
well-written game
you play this character called the
nameless one this little blue guy and
you wake up in a morgue
and it turns out that you're immortal
and every time you die you lose all your
memories
and so you've just been apparently
living this life
for a very long time and you meet all
these people in this crazy city called
sigil who know you
but you don't know yourself and you're
trying to figure out your name your
identity and
why do you have this curse where you
live forever but you keep forgetting
every time you get killed and it turns
out you weren't such a nice person
throughout this entire game world but
then again there's this question of well
if you can start over and you lose all
your memories do you have a chance for
redemption
or not so it's an incredible game
playing skate tournament and it's
actually another one of those games
where you can
you can never actually have a fight you
can just kind of talk your way out of
everything and
there's probably like a thousand pages
of dialogue inside the game those guys
have a lot of fun and a lot of drugs
making that game
do you think these are the these three
games are the kinds that would still be
okay to play today or are they forever
lost in time because uh
because we sort of are got desensitized
to the richness of
computer graphics and all those kinds of
things in modern games i think you can
enhance
these games because your storytelling
medium is so much more engaging
you know i was at the movie theater
before covet and the person to the left
of me was looking at their cell phone
during the movie and the person the
right of me was looking at their cell
phone they're just not engaged anymore
everybody is attention starved
and the video game is one of the last
mediums where you have undivided
attention of people
they're really into it they're all into
that thing and so i think the fact that
you have vr and ar and enhanced graphics
and
all these new gameplay mechanics it's a
value add instead of a value negative
because ultimately what are you doing
you're telling stories
and you're trying to connect people to
something maybe it's the nature of life
and death
or are we truly real or are we in a
simulation or not or something like it'd
be great to do 13th floor
as a game or something like that and the
question is well how good of a story can
you tell well you're constrained by your
storytelling tools and technology
the fact that games are so much more
advanced now means that you now have
many more dimensions of storytelling
available to you
and actually with ai now coming in and
really good ai coming in the next five
or ten years
your storytelling is not static anymore
the person can actually
majorly participate and change the
outcome in ways that were
previously unpredictable the other thing
is they're still educational you can
teach people concepts that they never
knew before
and it's like if you want to teach
people about bizarre geometries or
like minecraft is a great example a lot
of people learned how computers work
from redstone
think about that it's true yeah
yeah yeah use i mean yeah as we said
we're more and more going to be
living in the video game worlds might as
well
sort of uh as opposed to just make it
fun also expand
our knowledge expand our ability to
think ex
like uh explore different ideas and do
education broadly defined within those
video game worlds so we do the entirety
the entirety of life in in the video
game worlds
hopefully doesn't look like minecraft
but we'll see
you